[Music]
[Music]
i sort of felt that i just wanted to
tell like a night in the life of batman
you know
what what does a monday night look like
for batman but then when we hit on the
idea of of the blackout that that was
when it was like oh okay
that's the that's the hook
it all came out of that simple idea
that that he's got to get from one side
of gotham to the other in total blackout
with no support like he's marooned
abandoned
and the entirety of gotham is kind of
trying to sort of uh
get on top of him disable him take him
out take out emp a new villain
so uh yeah it's a very
simple concept i guess you know but it
all just happens within one evening
emp is
he essentially
he feeds on energy you know so that can
be electricity
um it can be emotional energy but he
can't really control it so he's been
subdued in arkham for years and years
they're basically transporting him from
the old
um
maybe slightly outdated uh arkham asylum
to the new facility black gay prison so
he's traveling in this kind of faraday
cage which is like a you know a box that
keeps the energy kind of contained
but you know without giving too much
away things go wrong he's a very
volatile character basically and and
and batman having to to get this guy
from one side to the other you know
during this kind of crazy night is um is
a challenge
it's a different muscle to flex for sure
you know um i've been lucky that i've
worked with them some of the best
writers in comics but um
yeah this is something different and and
it's definitely more challenging but
it's all the more uh rewarding for it i
find drawing the thumbnails is how i
write the script essentially
um i write a little uh outline of what's
going to
occur in in the issue and and then i
basically get to
to to doing the layout so and that's how
i can figure out the pace and and the
rhythm and the size of the scenes and
how how they all fit together
i'm not sure i'm quite why i just sit
down at a typewriter you know and
literally write us you know
30 page script and then then sit down
and draw it even though when i that's
what i receive from other writers i feel
like for for this thing um
it sort of suits my
just the way i do things that
i i sort of write it by drawing it you
know and i edit a lot and take stuff out
and everything else and i move pages
around and panels around but but i'm
essentially um i'm much more comfortable
telling the story visually that's uh
seemed to be the the way that it's
worked best for me
yeah i do love using black and what
better character is there to use black
on than batman you know i feel like
so many times when i've drawn him you
sort of do quite a lot of underdrawing
and the more black you add the he tends
to just look better and better and
better until you're just left with that
you know iconic silhouette that that we
all know
with the two piercing eyes and as if he
wasn't black enough you know i've called
this book one dark knight and it's set
during a blackout so it's there's even
more black
in this book which which sounds like you
know it could be easier but it's
actually super challenging to make that
work in a really effective way
one page that uh
remained exactly the same from the
tiniest little thumbnail when i had the
idea to the inks to the color and and
it's you know in the very early stages
of batman chasing emp across gotham it
has a huge bat symbol kind of you know
on city hall you know it was one of
those pages where i could see it
immediately and and i'm pleased to say
the final art kind of you know which is
quite rare for me i was i was kind of
reasonably happy with it so um that was
the page that really kind of summed up
the initial kind of you know momentum of
the story and it was a lot of fun to
draw
[Music]
[Music]
you know the evening that it got
announced you know but i was sort of you
know my phone was lit up for hours and
hours and hours it was it was uh you
know this is a story that's very dear to
my heart and then i put so so much into
it so to get that kind of response from
you know hopefully people are looking
forward to seeing the book it was just
you know the icing on on the cake for me
i've spent the last
year already on on this story um i'm
putting everything i've got
into it and yeah i can't wait for
everyone to see it
[Applause]
[Music]
you